rubbadubbers what used to be a home the
Saudi airstrikes targeted the town of
Abdullah in southern Yemen yeah it was a
horrific air strike they violated all
internationally recognized red lines it
resulted in the deaths of 17 people
including three women three children and
a pregnant woman of 8 months the attack
hasn't even excluded the rescuers as
world leaders meet at the UN's a General
Assembly in New York the United Nations
are can down to the attack but some on
the ground say words are not enough the
attack has taken place as the UN General
Assembly is holding its sessions
unfortunately the international
community has failed to do something
serious to stop the attacks on civilians
despite an international outcry when
they were began in 2015 the saudi-led
coalition plan to quickly defeat Yemen's
Houthis to reinstate the internationally
recognized government but the fighting
continues leaving a trail of death and
destruction with civilians often in the
firing line with Saudi Ouray led
military campaign against HOTAS now in
its fifth year Yemenis and others are
asking how many more innocent people
will die before serious action is taken
to stop the attacks coming atop al
Jazeera Sanaa